Wow I said I was going to introduce to
you two types of student secrets so I
just introduced a few arithmetic
progressions and this is one of the
examples I gave will be listing them out
when there's a good ratio we call it
something ever so slightly different we
call it instead so as an example like
you saw before I think they want to give
you as a half of the quarter what's an
eighth
you come up with anything you like you
could say the one plus three plus nine
etc that would be another GP geometric
progression now I'm going to put this
same question to you how do you sum and
that bad put that kind of regression how
do you sum this series evaluate what to
equal to for example suppose I stopped
somewhere why let's go with 204 really
okay that's a great job um how we going
to do this now we're going to do this
now I'm going to give you a moment to
think you've seen you worked out pretty
quickly actually the many times you've
seen it on before but you want that
pretty quickly a strategy that would
work here can you do something simple up
with this one I'll give you a moment to
fiddle with it and then we'll have a go
together
see the trouble you remember it don't
call youth you recognize the peak I
remember that ID on it
yep okay here's our gated often and
becomes easier to type of problem think
back to our first week in the
problem-solving strategies our priority
to you it's often better if you can
dissect something into a brilliant
answer pieces that are smaller right
and that's the reason why even though
doesn't look like this is actually you
help us why are the obvious okay how am
I got from this liner to this one what
I've done
I multiplied over 2 by 3 right now
another fun accident I chose three not
four or five or six or seven why do you
touch s three what what like the
importance of three to this series it's
the common ratio okay so since each of
them is multiplied by 3 multiplying by 3
one more time create a series that G
notice is very closely connected to this
series right it'll help if we have some
based on this this cheering option it's
um it's a sum of your ad will be not
losing it
how'd it go buddy you will gather each
other they're giving 6 times because you
don't have to write this that might be
helpful for you they're all powers of
three do you notice that this is 3 to
the 1 this is 3 squared
this happens to be 3 to 5 what's the
first term zero so you've got one two
three four five terms and then you've
got the distance of six in total so I'm
going to call this s 6 this is the sum
of the first six terms if this is s 6
and what is this
you taught me how often precisely
semiquaver
I just multiply the three right I'm
going to call it three lots of s6 and
you've ever I said to you by multiplying
by 3 because 3 is the common ratio this
series here has a lot in common with
this series
maybe if I draw right now another term
here it will become a little more
obvious 729 the last time what is the
second master Shi what it created in
fact it's a bit silly to write the
doctor thought because there's only one
tournament between 0 to 8 and 1 okay now
can you see that this second the green
series every single one of its terms
except the one every single one of these
challenges in the original series
you notice that except for the biggest
one yes
so therefore this is true whether
there's six terms or when there's 600
all these terms are going to overlap
with the previous one so therefore I'd
like to subtract one from the other
this is what I'm talking about that
tries to compile this because so many
terms you have had to deal with even
though I have an age of six
but if I do this subtraction there is
going to collapse everything now to
become something much smaller right you
can see that this term and this term are
going to match up this time this time
somewhere in here right this term and
this term this term of this term they'll
all match up and they're all subtraction
one of the old kids all right so I'll be
left with 720 sorry 29 a whole bunch of
zeroes all those terms of overlap and
then what it does at the end one
okay so kind of look at this and we'll
give this remember what the question was
it was find out the sum with six times
you actually can just punch into your
calculator but here you realize you two
need to if s 6 is what I'm after
[Music]
what will I do this is just a kind of a
problem piece of turn like if I caught s
6 if I call it X you would solve this in
like five seconds what would you like me
to do I can divide by 2 I will in a
second it's not it I probably should
this by 1/2 it why would I do that
look at the left hand side just a
counter up you're going to collect like
terms three of something take away one
of something is to something this is 728
and now it's just as it is I will divide
by two
yeah now what's wonderful let us
approach just like before is it now I
can generalize this if I had 600 terms
not six right this process would be just
as easy whereas if I was adding them up
of a calculator it would take me a
hundred times longer okay sir just like
we did you see how I have generalized a
peaking how am I going to handle a
general i GZ
well for starters how do I describe I
still have the first pen right hey I'll
call it the first night but to advance
from one term to the next I don't add a
common difference what do I do for this
GP I multiply by something I multiplied
by a common ratio so beep into ratio
rather than using difference that we go
boys are the ratio so the next term will
be a ah yes
well the next IV square right and then
I'm standing by factor of three terms
plus na cidade now you remember before
how he said the first term has no
differences the second term has one
difference the third term has two
differences do you notice is a patent
here there's a similarity this term has
no common ratios this one has one this
one has two common errors if the last
term is the nth term how many common
ratios do you expect it to have n minus
1 you happy that so this is the sum to
the nth term okay now what was the trick
I pulled out it's the clue that didn't
work very helpful what did I choose to
multiply by and truthful 5/3 because not
just I'd like to have three that's a
good number
it's the common ratio that's a
significant service right so what I'm
going to do moment multiply this by the
common ratio okay and you see what that
produces this will become a up this will
become
this will become a our cubes and then
all the way to the end what does the
last term become
did you make your index laws yeah it's
just one more lot of art all right I
multiply operation then what today what
was I able to do what they got to that
point I subtracted one from the other
right so I'm going to say this
take away this and you notice all these
terms collapsed right all the in-between
tones are left I was left with this guy
but last term then and then this guy
here the first term so how do I say that
details when our letter terms heron
theory is and very good these are the
ones that don't cancel with each other
take away a right now just like before
we collected like terms collecting like
terms is going to be tricky to you
because I don't know what R is but I
could still take out a common factor
which amounts to safety if I take out a
factor of SN right what gets us behind
while we're in a satirizing route you
can factorize here too you get yeah and
all I need to do the finish line doesn't
suggested for which was division right
I'm just going to divide by this right
so now I get this really nice looking
elegant formula for the sum should be in
and you can give it a go in this case
again if you like we did the sum to the
sixth term which would be out of the
first term 1 times 3 to the 6 minus 1
divided by 3
take my 1 and there's your bit to your
364 ok
the nice thing here if I can just say
how much as you want you want your key
terms
no problem okay you want to pick on your
terms no problem my calculator take care
of that eventually it won't occur
because the numbers get you but you get
the idea